vous voulez acheter une nouvelle télé
fin 2022 début 2023 on va dire fin 2022
parce que je tourne tout de suite fin
2022 mais vous y comprenez rien entre
les différentes technologies on vous
parle de connectique on vous parle de
plein de trucs ça vous parle pas
nécessairement je vais dégrosser tout ça
je vais venir vous aider pour vous aider
à choisir votre télé la télé de votre
cœur la télé de vos amours en cette fin
d'année voir début d'année prochaine ça
c'est cool et vous êtes prêts on y va
bon allez on y va on y va on y va
presque juste avant j'ai un petit
message pour vous allez on va d'abord
faire un petit tour du côté de chez mon
partenaire TCL qui aujourd'hui c'est
sponsorise la vidéo allez on y va c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisée
en partenariat avec TCL parce que quitte
à venir changer son téléviseur autant
venir voir ce qui se passe du côté de
chez TCL alors je vous ai déjà parlé TCL
notamment Ali Faya pas longtemps je vous
montre toutes leurs nouveautés TCL c'est
une marque qui propose des dernières
technologies accessibles à tous
téléviseurs de son réfrigérateur machine
à laver enfin bref on en a énormément
donc si vous voulez changer votre
télévision
upgradé ou avoir carrément une très très
belle télé si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
venez voir ce qui se passe du côté chez
TCL ici téléviseur c'est un 98 pouces
c'est un c735 juste énorme alors
rassurez-vous il y a pas que des 98
pouces il y a aussi des 65 pouces sont
déjà très grand et très bien il y a du
55 pouces et il y a énormément de taille
énormément de référence ici vous avez un
écran 4K Q LED IMAX n1s Dolby vision IQ
Dolby Atmos Todd rafraîchissement de 120
Hertz vous avez un super design avec des
bords très fins bref une télé de super
qualité pour venir regarder le foot mais
pas que alors là effectivement c'est un
98 pouces mais il existe d'autres
tailles pouvaient descendre sur ce
modèle là jusqu'en 43 pouces bref vous
trouverez forcément le modèle qui vous
convient TCL à 4 ambassadeurs de marque
qui sont pedris Rodrigo Raphaël Varane
et philoden donc si vous cherchez un
téléviseur pour regarder notamment le
grand événement qui aura lieu à la fin
de l'année pour le football et bien je
vous invite à venir regarder tous les
produits TCL des télés super
intéressantes je vous mets une fois de
plus le lien en bas dans la description
et merci à TCL d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo voilà comme ça vous savez tout
vous l'avez vu c'est intéressant on va
maintenant regarder essayer de
comprendre comment on va choisir son
téléviseur alors déjà il y a différentes
choses la première chose à regarder
c'est la taille et la taille c'est aussi
important en tout cas ici on se parle de
télévision pourquoi je vous explique
lorsque vous allez venir regarder pour
acheter une télé on vous parle de pouce
vous allez des toutes petites télé en 20
pouces et petit aujourd'hui jusqu'à du
98 pouces comme je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure il faut pas venir acheter
n'importe quoi je dirais que c'est ce
qui va vous permettre de choisir
vraiment la taille en pouce c'est la
distance que vous allez avoir par
rapport à votre écran à savoir que on va
regarder par exemple sur du 43 pouces
qui restent pas extrêmement très grand
mais qui conviendra encore aujourd'hui
on va considérer que le 43 pouces c'est
intéressant pour les tailles de 1 m à
environ 2 mètres 50 c'est pas une sauce
exacte mais c'est un petit peu ça l'idée
ensuite vous avez le 55 pouces à peu
près - 55 pouces c'est ce que j'ai à la
maison et qui me convient bien là vous
aide sur des dimensions des distances
pardon entre 2 mètres 50 à peu près 3
mètres 50 donc ça vous mesurez votre
canapé votre télé vous voyez ce que ça
raconte on peut monter encore plus avec
une 65 pouces ça commence à être quand
même pas mal grand le 65 pouces allez on
va se dire 3,50 m 4 ça va dépendre
vraiment de votre taille alors après
vous pouvez faire beaucoup plus grand
comme du 98 pouces mais là il vous faut
vraiment un très grand recul des grands
volumes des grands espaces à vous de
voir ce qui conviendra chez vous vous
mesurez la distance comme ça vous saurez
tout ça c'est le premier point à
connaître maintenant le deuxième point à
connaître qui a un point qui est
intéressant c'est la définition de votre
téléviseur la définition on en parle
beaucoup ça éduc 4K alors vous allez
avoir le Full HD vous allez avoir la 4K
UHD on parle même aujourd'hui du corps
alors il y a des télés qui existent en
8k mais je dirais qu'aujourd'hui la
norme c'est vraiment le 4K UHD si vous
avez sur des petites tailles d'écran
pendant des petites définition en Full
HD sera plus dans l'entrée de gamme
qu'on va aller là dessus aujourd'hui la
plupart des constructeurs vous propose
des télévisions en 4K UHD et il faut
savoir que la 8k c'est sympa mais la 8k
c'est quand même 4 fois plus grand que
la 4K UHD globalement il y a quasiment
personne qui a pas beaucoup de monde qui
va diffuser aujourd'hui en 8k ça ne sert
à rien d'avoir une télé en 8k je vous
conseillerais réellement même si vous
prenez une très grande taille d'écran
par exemple 98 pouces que je vous montre
tout à l'heure et bien on est sur la 4K
on n'est pas sur la 8k ça ne sert à rien
aujourd'hui d'aller prendre de la UK
donc ça en se le met un petit peu de
côté d'autant plus ça coûte extrêmement
cher 4K UHD c'est intéressant pourquoi
il y a plusieurs raisons si par exemple
vous avez un abonnement j'en sais rien à
mon abonnement Netflix qui n'est qu'un
abonnement en Full HD ça il faut le
savoir sauf si vous avez pris
l'abonnement 4K qui coûte plus cher et
bien vous avez des technologies regardez
dans ça veut dire que vous allez acheter
une technologie ce qu'on appellera c'est
de l'obscaling alors l'obscaling je suis
en train d'écrire très très mal
l'obscaling en fait ça va prendre quoi
ça va prendre votre définition en Full
HD et ça va venir rajouter des petites
informations dans les trous pour venir
la montée jusqu'en 4K donc en fait ça
vient la corriger d'un point de vue
numérique c'est pas réellement du 4K
sera toujours mieux que d'avoir du Full
HD donc regardez si le téléviseur vous
voulez acheter en 4K si vous regardez du
contenu en Full HD si vous avez de
l'ubscaling ça pourra venir vraiment
vous aider il y a un autre point qui est
important c'est la fréquence
c'est-à-dire le nombre d'images que vous
allez avoir par seconde qui elle
s'exprime en Hertz alors je vous
explique c'est très simple en fait dans
une seconde en règle générale au cinéma
vous avez 24 images c'est-à-dire que
dans une seconde entre pack pack vous
avez eu 24 images qui sont arrivés là
plus vous allez avoir d'image plus ça
sera fluide mais ça sert à rien de
regarder des films sans image par
seconde c'est la strictement aucun
intérêt donc ce qu'il faut que vous
regardiez c'est si par exemple vous êtes
amoureux ou amoureuse de sport là il
faut une fréquence d'image un petit peu
plus élevée pour apporter de la fluidité
si par exemple vous regardez je vous dis
il y a un match de foot et vous voyez
que bah la balle ça saccade un peu c'est
parce que vous avez un nombre d'images
par seconde qui est un petit peu peu
trop bas il faut que vous regardiez si
votre télé elle peut monter si par
exemple sur du 100 Hz si c'est une télé
sans Hertz c'est à dire que vous avez
probablement un mode Sport vous mettez
sur le mode sport et ça va venir booster
le nombre d'images par seconde sans
Hertz ça peut aussi être du 120 Hertz
donc ça faut vraiment venir le regarder
et ça c'est également intéressant parce
que vous allez jouer si vous êtes gamer
il y a des télés qui vont monter même en
144 Hz donc vous allez avoir beaucoup
d'images par seconde et ça c'est un vrai
confort lorsque vous allez lire jouer à
des jeux à des jeux de foot à des jeux
de foot et compagnie alors maintenant il
y a un autre sujet qui est extrêmement
intéressant où on se perd souvent un peu
c'est la technologie de la dalle il y a
plusieurs choses qui existent vous avez
classiquement les télé LED le tube
catholique c'est fini on va se parler de
télé LED voilà de la LED ok ça c'est
bien c'est la base c'est ok ça
fonctionne sauf que on a vu arriver il y
a pas longtemps ce qu'on appellera la
mini LED alors la mini LED c'est
exactement la même chose que la LED sauf
que comme son nom l'indique elle est
beaucoup plus petite elle est
miniaturisée je schématiserai réellement
là vous aviez une lettre comme ça et
bien là vous allez avoir beaucoup plus
de mini LED et le truc qui vachement
intéressant ici c'est que ça permet
vraiment de contrôler beaucoup mieux
l'image beaucoup plus en finesse donc ça
va apporter beaucoup plus de détails
dans l'image ça va apporter également
beaucoup plus de contrastes et beaucoup
plus de luminosité ça c'est vachement
bien c'est super intéressant donc
aujourd'hui je dirais que ça dépend une
fois de plus du budget qu'on peut mettre
mais si on peut le faire à tarif
équivalent allez sur de la mini LED vous
aurez des images de bien meilleur
qualité maintenant on sort un petit peu
de ça vous avez ce qu'on appelle le Q
LED alors le Q LED ça reste toujours de
la LED vous avez une couche qui va se
positionner entre le LCD et la LED c'est
ce qu'on appellera le quantum d'hôtes le
quantum d'Hot en fait ça va vous
permettre d'avoir une palette de couleur
qui va être plus étendue et d'avoir un
meilleur contraste mais à ne pas
confondre le Q LED qui reste de la LED
avec le OLED le OLED même s'il est
marqué LED dedans c'est pas de la LED il
faut imaginer en fait le OLED comme des
petits pixels c'est-à-dire que vous avez
des pixels de partout alors c'est tout
petit c'est tout fin et l'intérêt ici
c'est que chaque pixel va pouvoir venir
s'allumer ou s'éteindre indépendamment
il est auto et missif ça veut dire qu'il
va y mettre lui-même sa propre lumière
donc vous pouvez avoir un pixel par
exemple ici qui lui va y mettre une
lumière hyper forte celui à côté qui les
mettra pas de lumière bref on va pouvoir
vraiment venir tout gérer dans le
moindre détail le truc est super
intéressant avec le OLED c'est que
lorsque on veut par exemple une image
noire et bien ça réellement noire parce
que le pixel sera éteint donc on aura ce
qu'on appellera des vrais profondeurs de
noir et ça c'est super bien du détail
également une image plus fine plus
contrastée et des Noirs qui pour le coup
sont vraiment noir donc à privilégier
ici en fonction de votre budget je
dirais du mini LED également marche très
bien et on a aussi de très très jolies
résultats dans le cul LED alors après on
vous parle d'autres techno on vous parle
par exemple de HDR on vous parle
également de HDR 10 on vous parle
également de HDR 10 plus ça devient un
peu compliqué alors c'est pas réellement
si compliqué que ça HDR c'est de
l'anglais ça veut dire i dynamic range
ça vous permet d'avoir une gamme de
couleurs plus étendue d'avoir plus de
luminosité et une meilleure profondeur
de l'image en gros ça vient bosser pour
venir améliorer la qualité de votre
image ça c'est pour le HDR de base sauf
que il y a eu des évolutions on a eu le
hdr10 le HDR 10 c'est la qualité Blu-ray
ni plus ni moins c'est à dire que 10
pourquoi parce que vous avez 10 bits et
10 bits s'intéressant pourquoi parce que
vous avez un milliard de couleurs donc
une plus grosse richesse de couleur donc
des images qui sont beaucoup plus belles
et puis après il y a une évolution du
HDR 10 c'est le hdr10 plus qu'il a bien
concurrencé Dolby et le Dolby vision
donc regardez parce que c'est quand même
vachement bien aujourd'hui alors vous
pouvez avoir des télés qui vont être en
Dolby vision Dolby vision de division it
you on va pas rentrer très très loin
dans les détails ici mais ça c'est gâche
de qualité en terme d'optimisation de
votre image mais regardez quand même
c'est important d'avoir une télé on se
dirait en hdr10 HDR 10 plus alors quand
on parle de télé on parle également de
son on parle d'audio alors en règle
générale ce qu'on va venir retrouver au
niveau des télés c'est du Dolby Atmos le
Dolby Atmos également une technologie
qui appartient à Dolby il faut proposer
des licences aux fabricants alors l'idée
du Dolby Atmos ça fait quoi ça vient à
partir dans son stéréo vous créez
artificiellement un rendu en trois
dimensions pour vous soyez plus immergé
ça fonctionne bien maintenant si vous
voulez réellement avoir un son en trois
dimensions faut venir acheter une barre
de son en plus ça c'est vachement bien
parce que pour le coup vous aurez une
vraie bonne restitution alors ici on va
pas parler de barre de son mais c'est un
sujet intéressant parce que si vous
voulez une très belle image ça peut être
aussi super intéressant
avoir une très belle restitution sonore
donc posez-vous vraiment la question si
vous reste un petit peu de budget
d'avoir une barre de son il y en a
différents tarifs on peut commencer à
faire des choses très bien sans
forcément dépenser des sommes folles
puisqu'on se parle de barre de son je
voulais qu'on se parle aussi de
connectique ça c'est super important
alors aujourd'hui on a du HDMI le HDMI
c'est quoi le HDMI c'est une connectique
ça vous permet de faire circuler l'audio
et la vidéo il y a une petite
particularité qui est intéressante si
vous vous voulez avoir une barre de son
c'est de prendre du HDMI arc à RC ou Ark
comme vous voulez ah tiens c'est pas eux
ça permet de faire un truc que vous
retrouverez pas avec l'HDMI pure c'est à
dire que si par exemple vous avez une
console ici vous voyez j'en sais rien
une console quelle qu'elle soit et bien
vous allez avoir votre HDMI qui va se
brancher ici vous avez donc avoir
l'image qui part de votre console et
l'audio qui part de votre console et qui
arrive jusqu'à votre téléviseur mais
votre téléviseur lui il est incapable
d'envoyer à votre console de l'audio
sauf que si vous voulez brancher une
barre de son en HDMI et bien il vous
faut du HDMI arc pas pour envoyer de
l'image mais lui pour pouvoir envoyer
l'audio directement de votre téléviseur
à votre barre de son donc si vous n'avez
pas d'admi arc vous ne pourrez va avoir
ici de barre de son donc bon posez-vous
quand même la question regardez bien si
vous voulez avoir une barre de son
d'abord de l'HDMI à RC et pour toutes
les consoles de nouvelles génération il
vous faut aussi du HDMI mais il vous
faut du HDMI 2.1 pour pouvoir envoyer
tout le signal envoyer la purée en gros
autre qui peut être intéressant au
niveau de la connectique et bien c'est
d'avoir de l'USB pour pouvoir brancher
un disque dur pour pouvoir dire brancher
une clé USB avec des photos je sais pas
faire une soirée diapo avec Mamie par
exemple on peut le faire pour pouvoir
dire brancher un appareil photo bref ce
que vous voulez l'USB c'est quand même
pas mal autre petit point puisqu'on
parlait de l'HDMI posez-vous vraiment la
question d'avoir le nombre de ports HDMI
qui est en conséquence par rapport à
tous les appareils si vous avez une xbox
si vous avez une playstation j'en sais
rien si vous avez beaucoup d'appareil
regardez quand même d'avoir suffisamment
de port HDMI de libre regardez si vous
voulez brancher une box enfin bref
regardez vraiment d'avoir le nom adéquat
qui correspond à vos besoins le truc qui
peut aussi être intéressant c'est
d'avoir une prise jack si vous voulez
brancher un casque ça se fait pas trop
aujourd'hui c'est plus du Bluetooth donc
une fois de plus il vous faut du
Bluetooth bien évidemment ici et puis
bien évidemment du wifi le wifi parce
qu'on se parle aujourd'hui de Smart TV
on peut voir se connecter alors
puisqu'on se parle de Smart TV
posez-vous la question de l'os derrière
qu'est-ce que vous avez quelle est
l'expérience des fois les expériences
sont pas folles folles moi ce que je
vous recommande réellement c'est d'avoir
du Google TV Google TV pourquoi parce
que Google TV c'est vachement bien si
par exemple vous voulez chercher un
programme en particulier Google TV vient
le chercher sur l'ensemble des
applications existantes ça va être
Molotov ça va être sur les différentes
chaînes de télé ça va être sur Netflix
et sur mycanal bref là vous aurez des
abonnements c'est super bien pour bien
trouver tout ce que vous voulez en plus
de ça il va venir vous connaître vous
proposera des films qui correspondent à
vos goûts donc bon Google TV ça marche
quand même vachement bien il y a un
autre truc qui est intéressant également
à venir regarder si sur une télé c'est
la question de pouvoir envoyer du
contenu depuis un smartphone depuis une
tablette donc c'est quand même très très
bien d'être compatible Apple AirPlay 2
si vous avez un iPhone pour pouvoir
venir caster du contenu de la même
manière le fait d'être chromecast pour
pouvoir venir caster directement depuis
un appareil Android comme ça vous avez
un peu la solution des deux côtés il y a
également miracast donc regardez
vraiment ce qui est compatible une fois
de plus en fonction de vos appareils en
fonction de vos besoins l'autre sujet
qui est intéressant comme on est sur la
télé connectée et bien c'est le fait
d'avoir un assistant vocal alors il y a
certaines marques qui ont leur propres
assistants vocaux je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne sert globalement à
pas grand chose même si c'est un petit
plus à être un petit plus ce qu'on vous
recommande enfin moi ce que je vous
recommande surtout d'avoir aujourd'hui
bien Google assistant parce que ça reste
quand même une des grosses références et
si vous êtes en plus sur un Google TV
Google assistant va vraiment être là
pour le coup pour vous assister et vous
aider ou alors sinon c'est forcément
Amazon Alexa donc bon à voir ça ça peut
aussi être intéressant en fonction une
fois de plus de ce que vous venez
utiliser la maison je vous parlais je
reviens très très rapidement en arrière
bon il y a un autre qui peut aussi être
intéressant si par exemple vous n'avez
pas d'admi arc et que vous voulez
envoyer de l'audio vers un amplificateur
j'en sais rien et bien vous pouvez
regarder pour avoir une sortie optique
ça permet d'envoyer le signal audio ça
se peut aussi être intéressant ça dépend
une fois de plus de votre setup à la
maison voilà on a regardé quasiment les
éléments les plus importants il y aura
toujours des petites techno des petites
choses en plus mais plus vous allez
monter en gamme et plus vous en dorez en
gros plus vous allez dépenser d'argent
et plus vous en aurez pour votre argent
maintenant je donne quelques petites
astuces pour éviter des fois d'être un
peu déçu faut prendre un truc à venir
regarder lorsque vous voulez acheter une
télé à moins que vous connaissiez
réellement la marque le modèle vous
soyez sûr de vous des fois elle est un
coup d’œil dans des magasins c'est bien
pour regarder il y a plusieurs choses à
venir regarder par vous même le premier
truc c'est ce qu'on appellera l'angle de
vision l'angle de vision il est super
important parce qu'en fait ça va
correspondre si vous êtes face à votre
télé voyez bien l'image la qualité et là
tout va bien mais si vous vous décalez
un petit peu trop sur le côté si vous
vous rendez compte à ce moment-là et
bien que sur le côté vous voyez beaucoup
moins bien que la qualité d'image n'est
plus trop là ça veut dire que l'angle de
vision de votre télévision est pas
extraordinaire auquel cas il faut
peut-être aller en voir une autre parce
que si comme chez moi moi chez moi j'ai
la télé j'ai un fauteuil et le canapé
qui a plus sur le côté là si on a pas un
bon angle de vision et bien on est mort
on verra pas la télé donc venez
l'essayer par vous même regarder
déplacez-vous autour et voyez si l'angle
de vision est bon ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est est-ce que
votre dalle elle va être réfléchissante
je mets un petit air pour réfléchissante
est-ce qu'elle va renvoyer la lumière si
par exemple vous avez des baies vitrées
chez vous et que vous avez une dalle qui
est très réfléchissante bien ça peut
être un petit peu embêtant à voir si
elle est énormément ou pas ce que je
vous recommande de faire à ce moment-là
c'est que vous prenez votre Smartphone
vous l'allumez et vous comparez d'une
dinde à l'autre alors vous verrez
fatalement la lumière de la torche de
votre smartphone ça c'est clair vous
voyez faites comme ça vous la verrez et
vous voyez c'est très réfléchissant ou
pas vous comparez entre différents
modèles à différents tarifs et vous vous
ferez votre avis par vous-même et puis
le troisième point ça va correspondre un
peu je dirais au gaming aujourd'hui on
sait qu'on aime beaucoup jouer sur les
télés énormément il y a un truc à
connaître c'est le temps de latence
qu'on appellerait également Lean poutlag
et quand on est gamer on veut une
latence très basse surtout sur les jeux
où on vient shooter on veut que ça
marche directement ça peut vraiment
faire la différence si on joue vraiment
un niveau qui est assez élevé regardez
quel est votre input lag s'il est je
dirais vers zéro virgule une
milliseconde vous êtes bon si par contre
vous êtes à 5 millisecondes bon c'est
pas ouf ça dépend une fois de plus des
usages de chacun donc voilà j'espère que
ça vous aura aidé que ça vous aura
permis un peu d'en savoir un peu plus de
dégrossir un peu tout ça quant à l'achat
de votre téléviseur fin 2022 début 2023
dites-moi dans les commentaires si ça
vous a aidé aiguillé ou alors pas du
tout est-ce que vous connaissiez ces
points est-ce que vous en connaissez
d'autres qui sont importants est-ce que
vous avez vous des propres astuces à
venir ajouter des bons conseils
marquez-les en bas dans les commentaires
il faut que tout le monde puisse venir
s'entraîner ça c'est super important
j'espère que vous aura aidé j'ai
vraiment essayé d'aller à l'essentiel au
plus clair pour venir dégrossir après
n'oubliez pas que en règle générale plus
vous allez monter en prix et plus vous
allez monter en gamme et plus vous en
aurez pour votre argent donc je vous
invite à venir jeter un petit coup
d'oeil à tout ça regardez les vidéos
allez en magasin puis c'est tout ça et
regarder voilà je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao